what happens to this perfect day by Ira  Levin when it is placed into scp-914 one  flash drive containing a text file of  this perfect day by Ira Levin was placed  into the Clockworks on the setting very  fine the output produced was the  following one flash drive containing a  single dot jar executable every attempt  made to decompile the file was met with  failure and a notice of quote technical  difficulty when executed a log file was  created depicting the most effective way  of life for everyone in a 200 meter  radius followed by 10 genome sequences  with five for each gender intern  bubilier noted interesting to say the  least although I don't see myself  becoming a plumber anytime soon